cómo
[Música]
ucrania ya es candidato oficial a entrar
en la unión europea y estoy seguro de
que la mayoría recordáis haber visto
titulares como este la unión europea
otorga a ucrania el estatus de candidato
en un momento histórico de la misma
forma que seguro todos o al menos muchos
de vosotros habéis presenciado este
histórico momento
la bandera de la unión europea ya ondea
en el parlamento de ucrania y en cierto
modo creo que no cabe la sorpresa tanto
desde el punto de vista de la cohesión
política europea como por supuesto desde
el punto de vista militar ucrania de
hecho méritos más que suficientes para
ganarse el estatus oficial de candidato
no sólo por su incansable y valiente
lucha contra un invasor muy superior en
fuerza sino también porque podemos decir
claramente que en la política europea
hay un antes y un después de la invasión
rusa de ucrania al fin y al cabo ucrania
fue atacada precisamente por querer
formar parte de la familia occidental
sin embargo un momento porque esto es
visual polític sin lugar a dudas haberse
convertido en candidato oficial a ser
miembro del club comunitario es un
enorme espaldarazo para la motivación y
la confianza de los soldados y el pueblo
ucraniano de eso no cabe dudas sin
embargo echa el freno porque el camino
hasta la integración no será
precisamente ni fácil ni rápido gran ya
no tiene un momento fácil hacia la
adhesión a la unión europea los
profundos desafíos que plantea el
legítimo deseo del país de unirse al
bloque también deben ser reconocidos
queréis saber a qué obstáculo se
enfrenta a ucrania para poder entrar la
unión europea podrá realmente llegar a
convertirse en un país miembro cuáles
son los principales cambios que tiene
que llevar a cabo pues queridos amigos
amigas en este vídeo vamos a responder a
estas y otras preguntas y por cierto si
os gusta lo que hacemos ya podéis
contribuir activamente a que visual
político siga creciendo y sobre todo
siga mejorando con más y mejor contenido
así que si queréis apoyar este proyecto
y de paso recibir boletines y glitter
merchandising y mucho más ahora podéis
formar parte de nuestra comunidad en
patria os dejamos toda la info la
descripción pero dicho esto vamos ya con
ucrania
[Aplausos]
[Música]
seamos claros entrar en la unión
europea' no es como entrar en la otan
formar parte del club comunitario
implica incorporar un montón de leyes y
realizar un montón de cambios en el
derecho o la política y la economía de
los países candidatos por ejemplo a
croacia le llevó ni más ni menos que
diez años convertirse en un estado
miembro evidentemente este plazo no es
fijo depende de cada país a finlandia
por ejemplo que ya tenía instituciones
democráticas y una economía de libre
mercado asentada pues le llevó sólo dos
años pero creo que todos absolutamente
todos convendremos que ucrania pues está
más cerca de la acrobacia reunión
europea que de finlandia
[Música]
por ejemplo para poder ser miembro del
club comunitario se tiene que respetar
sí o sí el artículo 2 del tratado de la
unión europea o un artículo que suele
terminar siendo un dolor de cabeza para
muchos de los países que quieren entrar
en la unión la unión está fundada en los
valores del respeto a la dignidad humana
la libertad la democracia la igualdad el
imperio de la ley y el respeto a los
derechos humanos incluyendo a las
personas que pertenecen a minorías
artículo 2 del tratado de la unión
europea la pregunta es cumple o crank ya
con todo esto pues saber cómo decirlo
creo que todos sabéis que aquí en visual
político condenamos rotundamente la
invasión rusa y que nos solidarizamos
con ucrania en su estoica resistencia
pero que queréis que os diga no seríamos
objetivos y pintaremos al país de color
de rosa al fin y al cabo si lucha por
ser el país más pobre de europa que es
precisamente por algo no os parece
[Música]
hoy por hoy tanto la política como la
economía de ucrania están muy lejos de
los estándares occidentales por ejemplo
su economía está muy intervenida por el
estado existen controles de precios y
unos pocos oligarcas millonarios
monopolizan los sectores estratégicos de
la economía nacional oligarcas que por
supuesto de una forma u otra tienden a
ser protegidos por el propio aparato
público de hecho la corrupción en el
país es rampante según transparencia
internacional
ucrania es el segundo país más corrupto
de toda europa después de rusia y no se
puede decir que existan muchos controles
para intentar frenarla todo esto es lo
que explica que ucrania sea
exageradamente pobre para los estándares
europeos para que os hagáis una idea
hablamos de un país cuyo pib per cápita
fue en el 2021 que apenas el 40% del pib
per cápita de bulgaria que es
actualmente el país más pobre de la
unión europea y por supuesto con la
guerra las cosas se han puesto mucho
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas creo que tiene
que hacer tantos cambios que algunos
expertos estiman que el periodo de
adhesión si se produce finalmente puede
durar entre 10 y 20 años o una eternidad
ahora bien exactamente exactamente
cuáles son las principales reformas que
ucrania tiene que llevar a cabo para
convertirse en un país miembro cuáles
son los principales obstáculos pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
el difícil proceso europeo
a ver si tuviéramos que definir de
alguna forma la unión europea pues
quizás podríamos hacerlo con tres
palabras burocracias y normativas
interminables así que el llamado proceso
de adhesión implica que los países que
quieren formar parte de la unión tienen
que adoptar primero toda la normativa
comunitaria de golpe hablamos de un
proceso que en total se divide en seis
etapas la aplicación formal de la
membresía el estatus de candidato la
presión las negociaciones la
ratificación y finalmente ya la
integración pues bien tras su
ratificación como candidato oficial
ucrania acaba de entrar de lleno en la
tercera etapa la pre adhesión
durante esta etapa ucrania o cualquier
otro país candidato tiene que acordar
junto con la comisión europea la llamada
estrategia de preadhesión esta
estrategia consiste en fijar una serie
de directrices para que ucrania incluyan
su jurisprudencia las reformas
administrativas políticas y económicas
que le permitan al estado aplicar las
leyes europeas y no hablamos
precisamente de un cambio menor sino de
más de
130.000 páginas de legislación europea y
ahora ucrania tendrá que introducir en
su sistema político y evidentemente eso
es mucha muchísima legislación y un
costosísimo proceso de cambios internos
en todas las estructuras del país
nadie dijo que fuera fácil por supuesto
la economía no es una excepción ucrania
tendrá que poner patas arriba y cambiar
por completo su modelo económico para
desarrollar una economía de mercado
funcional y libre que pueda operar sin
restricciones en el mercado común y esto
esto es mucho más fácil es decir que de
hacer
no olvidéis que ucrania es un país que
procede del antiguo bloque comunista de
la más dura unión soviética y que nunca
ha llevado a cabo reformas profundas en
su sistema pero de todo esto lo haremos
en un momento la pregunta ahora es
entonces es que ucrania parte de cero
pues bien lo cierto es que no no parte
de cero pero casi y es que veréis
ucrania está asociada con la unión
europea a través del acuerdo de
asociación firmado en el año 2014 y que
está en vigor desde el 2016 en virtud de
este acuerdo el recientemente convertido
en el país más especializado en ya
billings de todo el mundo ha ido
implementando poco a poco algunos
cambios durante los últimos años el
acuerdo de asociación de ucrania con la
unión europea obliga aquí a emprender
reformas legales este acuerdo por cierto
tiene mucho pero que mucho que ver con
la deriva que han tomado los
acontecimientos
[Música]
y es que veréis gracias a este acuerdo
la economía ucraniana comenzó a girar a
toda velocidad del este hacia el oeste
esto es desde rusia y la llamada
comunidad de estados independientes
hacia la unión europea de hecho el
comercio con el bloque comunitario
supuso en 2020 más del 40 por ciento de
todas las exportaciones ucranianas 8
veces más que las exportaciones a rusia
hablamos de un proceso que ahora además
con invasión de putin lejos de frenarse
se ha acelerado todavía más fijaos 28 de
abril la unión europea suspende los
aranceles a las importaciones de ucrania
durante un año cif lo agradece 29 de
junio ucrania y la unión europea firman
un acuerdo de liberación del transporte
por carretera el acuerdo elimina la
necesidad de que los transportistas
ucranianos obtengan permisos para entrar
a la unión europea e incluso por fin se
ha vinculado la red eléctrica de
ucraniana con la red europea 1 de julio
de 2000 22 teles que dice que ucrania
ahora está exportando electricidad a la
unión europea sea como sea el caso es
que según palabras de la propia ínsula
von der leyen gracias a este acuerdo de
asociación ucrania habría implementado
ya a cerca de un 70 por ciento de la
legislación
y los principios europeos
por ejemplo entre otros muchos cambios
se han mejorado los procesos de
contratación pública las estadísticas
oficiales han aproximado a los
estándares europeos y se ha comenzado a
reformar por completo el mercado
energético el cual hasta ahora estaba
totalmente controlado por el estado
incluso se ha desarrollado una
administración digital
sin embargo echa el freno porque
hablamos de ucrania y cómo decirlo las
cifras de von der leyen no se las cree
ni ella misma aunque se lleva tres
litros de cocacola la distancia que un
separa ucrania de los estándares
europeos sigue siendo simple y
llanamente abismal queréis algunos
ejemplos concretos pues fijaos
antes veíamos que según transparencia
internacional es el segundo país más
corrupto de europa pues eso es tan solo
el principio en el índice de libertad
económica y ucrania ocupa el puesto 130
de 177 países y está situada entre
estados como banda la india o la propia
billion rusia de alexander lukashenko en
el índice de libertad humana del fraser
institute ocupa el puesto 98
prácticamente a la par como última fase
o kazajistán o mozambique en el rule of
law index que mide la calidad judicial
el puesto 74 en el índice de libertad de
prensa el puesto 106 y en el índice de
calidad democrática el 86 vamos que lo
miremos por donde lo miremos ucrania
está muy pero que muy lejos del club
europeo y sí gracias al acuerdo de
asociación no se parte de cero pero el
camino por delante es largo muy largo y
ojo que no sólo hablamos de aplicar la
normativa europea con eso en ucrania no
bastaría porque queréis saber
exactamente a qué escollo se enfrenta el
país desde el esquí pues atentos
[Música]
un reto colosal
amigos amigas una vez termine la guerra
y ucrania puedo centrarse al cien por
cien en su reconstrucción en todos los
sentidos tanto física como económica
social y política el gobierno de turno
tendrá que poner patas arriba al país
para cumplir los requisitos de acceso a
la unión europea y lo tendrá que hacer
en un montón de frentes al mismo tiempo
tendrá por supuesto que poner en marcha
las reformas que exige bruselas pero
también tendrá que volver a poner en pie
al país empezando claro está por las
propias infraestructuras básicas es
evidente que un país destruido física e
institucionalmente tendrá prácticamente
imposible entrar en la unión europea
haga las reformas que haga sería por así
decirlo demasiado caro por eso cuando
termine la guerra y el gobierno
ucraniano tendrá que esforzarse no sólo
en cumplir con la legislación
comunitaria y las peticiones de bruselas
también tendrá que actuar en estos dos
frentes
[Música]
según estimaciones del gobierno
ucraniano solo para reconstruir puentes
e infraestructuras básicas y edificios
harán falta entre 100.000 y 200.000
millones de dólares y si a eso le
sumamos la recuperación del tejido
económico y productivo de ucrania la
cuenta total puede superar ampliamente
los 500 a los 600 mil millones
[Música]
obviamente esto es algo que bruselas no
puede ignorar al hablar de todo un
candidato a formar parte de la unión
europea en otras palabras que al final
las instituciones comunitarias tendrán
que poner en marcha una especie de plan
marshall para apoyar la reconstrucción
la unión europea creará una plataforma
para la reconstrucción de ucrania la
plataforma se utilizará para determinar
las necesidades de inversión coordinar
la acción y canalizar los recursos dijo
von der leyen el reto aquí es conseguir
que este plan de recuperación se aplique
sin que el dinero termine en los
bolsillos de los oligarcas que desde la
caída de la unión soviética han
controlado la economía del país porque
evidentemente si la unión europea
destina un montón de dinero que luego no
sirve para nada eso podría muy pero que
muy cuesta arriba el proceso de adhesión
pulse heladas parece confiar en que aquí
lleva a cabo un amplio programa de
liberación económica pero realmente lo
hará está por ver con todo esto no es lo
más difícil
lo más difícil es que ucrania tendrá que
cambiar por completo su naturaleza de
país como ya hemos dicho tendrá que
aplicar la legislación comunitaria pero
con eso no basta también tendrá que
poner fin a la corrupción estratosférica
y por ejemplo tendrá que crear entre
otras cosas un nuevo sistema judicial
que realmente sea garantista
todo esto creo que es amigos amigas son
cosas muy fáciles de decidir pero muy
difíciles de llevar a cabo como puede
ucrania dar un giro de 180 grados lo
permitirán los oligarcas y ojo que
hablamos de un país que tiene cientos y
cientos y cientos de miles millones de
jóvenes emigrantes a lo largo y ancho de
toda europa jóvenes con destrezas
profesionales y en muchos casos buena
formación académica jóvenes que podrían
llegar a jugar un papel clave en el
proceso de reconstrucción económica e
institucional que el país necesita
llevar a cabo antes de poder acceder a
la unión europea de hecho seamos claros
sin atraer a la diáspora de vuelta es
muy pero que muy difícil prácticamente
imposible que ucrania consiga en un
período de tiempo razonable el nivel de
prosperidad desarrollo y riqueza
necesarios como para completar sueldos a
la unión europea pero claro para que
puedan retornar invertir o montar
empresas hace falta sobre todo dos cosas
seguridad jurídica y mercados abiertos
la pregunta es cómo se pueden conseguir
estas dos cosas
pues bien hay quien dice que una forma
de conseguirlo sería emular el modelo de
las zonas económicas especiales de dubai
como es el caso del centro financiero de
esta ciudad allí son jueces británicos
quienes forman a otros jueces e imparten
justicia siguiendo un marco de derecho
especial un marco de derecho muy
garantista y muy atractivo para las
empresas e inversores extranjeros ahora
bien es esto realista cabe alguna remota
posibilidad de que esto sea posible en
ucrania pues probablemente no pero
amigos amigas casos como el del oligarca
rinat ajmétov paradójicamente dan
ciertas esperanzas a gm todos para
quienes no le conozcáis es el hombre más
rico de todo el país y un empresario que
siempre tuvo conexiones muy cercanas con
rusia y con los entornos pro rusos de la
política ucraniana de hecho ha sido el
principal financiador y el líder en la
sombra del ruso filo partido de las
regiones con el cual llegó a ser
diputado incluso en la rada suprema pues
bien atentos a esta declaración el mal
no puede quedar impunes los crímenes de
rusia contra ucrania en nuestro pueblo
son atroces los culpables deben ser
hechos responsables esta demanda es uno
de los primeros pasos legales
internacionales contra rusia para
detener sus crímenes la destrucción de
la economía ucraniana y el saqueo de los
activos ucranianos rinat akhmetov
oligarca ucraniano ya sea por dinero o
por tener un futuro en ucrania o por un
repentino amor a la patria o por todas
estas cosas a la vez el discurso de
ajmétov propietario entre otras muchas
cosas de la famosa acería azov tal ha
cambiado radicalmente
no
como el muchos otros oligarcas pro rusos
están sufriendo multimillonarias
pérdidas patrimoniales por culpa de la
invasión rusa sin ir más lejos el
patrimonio de ajmétov se ha reducido
desde su pico de 16.000 millones de
dólares en el 2012 a unos 4 mil 200
millones según datos de forbes pero por
contradictorio que pueda parecer esta
situación podría tener un lado positivo
muchos de los grandes oligarcas
ucranianos han visto como una proporción
relevante de sus activos productivos se
han hecho añicos por culpa de rusia y
con ellos buena parte de su capacidad
para influir en las comunidades locales
y en la política nacional
es decir la destrucción de una parte de
su riqueza y de su influencia junto a la
asistencia internacional y el cambio de
prioridades de que puede hacer que estos
oligarcas terminen aceptando cambios en
las reglas de juego para convertirse en
empresarios en un mercado competitivo
pensad que si quiere realmente entrar en
la unión europea va a tener sitios y que
poner coto a todos estos oligarcas
digamos que es muy probable que la
reconstrucción la presión social y ahora
sí la seguridad nacional valga mucho
muchísimo más que los sobornos y las
presiones de estos oligarcas oligarcas
que además tendrán que expiar su pasa de
inclinación pro rusa con lo que no sería
extraño verlos enarbolar de repente la
bandera de la unión europea y la reforma
en síntesis para poder convertirse en un
miembro de pleno derecho de la unión
europea que tendrá que convertirse en
una democracia de cierta calidad tendrá
que adoptar una economía de libre
mercado tendrá que introducir en su
derecho y luego aplicar la extensísima
legislación europea tendrá que
reconstruir sus infraestructuras tendrá
que promover tasas de crecimiento
importantes acabar con el poder de los
oligarcas y cambiar por completo sus
instituciones una lista de tareas
larguísima y muy pero que muy complicada
pero por un momento porque ni siquiera
se trata solo de ucrania para poder
admitir como miembro de pleno derecho a
un país tan grande y con tantas
dificultades puede que la propia unión
europea también tenga que cambiar me
estoy refiriendo por ejemplo a cosas
como las reglas de unanimidad
en muchos campos la unión europea exige
la unanimidad de todos los países
miembros para poder sacar adelante
diferentes iniciativas el problema es
que la unión europea se está haciendo
tan grande que eso resulta cada vez más
complicado sobre todo cuando tenemos en
cuenta las enormes diferencias que
existen entre los países miembros y para
colmo ucrania sería un poderoso aliado
de polonia un país que no se llevaba
particularmente bien con bruselas
y yo juego que este es un riesgo del que
algunos líderes europeos ya hablan
abiertamente sea como sea ya lo veis la
entrada de ucrania en la unión europea
si es que llega a producirse algún día
será un proceso muy pero que muy largo
muy difícil y sujeto a muchas
condiciones pero llegados hasta aquí
turno para ti cristo plan ya terminará
integrándose en el club comunitario
conseguir aquí realizar todas las
reformas políticas y económicas
necesarias como para convertir a ucrania
en un país homologable a los miembros
comunitarios déjanos tus impresiones por
aquí abajo en los comentarios y ya sabes
si te ha gustado este vídeo no olvides
darle a like i suscribirte a nuestro
canal para no perderte ninguna novedad
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]